hi I'm Mike Schneider I'm looking
forward to telling you about our new
frontiers in cancer genomics course it's
an exciting new area there's lots of
exciting things happening and you're
gonna learn about them in this course
cancer is a really really important
disease 50% of men and 33% of women will
get cancer at some point in their
lifetime we need better ways of diagnose
cancer and we also very sorely needed
better treatments cancer is a genetic
disease almost all cancers are the
results of multiple mutations cancer is
also a genomic disease and that every
cancer cell has a unique collection of
changes that cause cells to grow
uncontrollably if we really want under
seeing cancer and also treat cancer we
have to look very carefully at the DNA
of their cancer what we're gonna learn
in this class difference between
inherited and sporadic cancers so
inherited cancers the familiar cancers
are tying that run in families we're
also going to learn about classifying
cancers based on the genome differences
not just where they come from very
importantly going to understand how
cancer cells evolved to become resistant
to treatments there's a number of
community initiatives for enhancing
cancer research and understanding how
cancer occurs and finally you're gonna
hear some very cold primary research
that's occurring in the cancer field and
some of the exciting developments that
are going on and certainly you're gonna
hear about current challenges in terms
of trying to understand treat and
research cancer so overall it's going to
be incredibly exciting course there's so
many new developments that you're going
to learn about can't wait to get started